but it sounds like game works this one
exactly how I planned it - you didn't
expect this from me which is why you
lost you get too close to a livewire and
you pay the price Shh it's okay
what's up everybody it's Tuesday
we're here with that apex legends season
- I'm excited you're not a channel
Watson I guess
well yeah you guys season two started
battle charge is here by the way hi I'm
Persia Eric's back hello yesterday I
know you guys mess around but yeah you
know he's very important in this office
so all right so all right yeah it's not
bad
yeah but is it that much different from
that one oh maybe that's why it's not
bad what it's like no I like that one
actually but the other ones you were
showing me I did not like as much here's
this one which I don't know how I feel
about it
that one's like a motion-capture
bodysuit and then there's that one so I
can buy a skin I told the chat they can
choose I know what they're gonna do to
me this is probably the for me on a
personal level the best one but yeah I
would say ASIS Pyke's looks the best but
because this one's like the camo
military that's alright I'd rather have
more colorful yeah like red jacket yeah
and then there's yeah motion capture or
whatever cyber security that one's not
bad either I just don't like her her
head in this one yes I'm gonna show the
finisher the other one in case you don't
want to see it I've never played Watson
so this is gonna be interesting
cyber we want you to pick the one you
don't like hey we gotta go that's good
cyber so we're one for one right now
chat will eventually pick up as I like
girl do summer written she has a pretty
good not that one
that one yeah that's pretty cool I wish
these kind of oh they do yeah there you
go yes ace ace and fly by electric
sniper ace please okay good we got well
more for you just take it ace we've
already had like for the chat I will buy
all three you guys I don't even have
enough to buy yeah yeah it's not cheap I
was season by the end they said you can
actually get enough to get one so
there's our ace we got our squad here
there's a battle pass as well so you
know challenges but there's also yeah
the daily challenge is I just wanna go
through this real quick and then we'll
get we'll get into a game so here's your
daily challenges there's weekly
recurring challenges and then there's
your like weekly challenges none of them
are alike if you guys played 49 or
anything like that it's none of them are
like that go here find this kind of
thing so it's mainly like do damage drop
somewhere you get ten knock downs with
the ellow star cheap though they said
that it's supposed to drop more often so
we'll see all right let's go let's do a
thing and hope I had a problem getting a
match earlier it was like connecting and
then it would like disconnect or like it
wouldn't connect it would like it would
get to this point where we're stuck at
right now mm-hm and then it would like
kind of uh sorry I'm like reading
someone's child I don't have dropped
frames so I don't know I don't know Auto
hopefully if it's is itself for you but
up see it would see it connected to a
match this now right and then it would
like to see if it goes to finish back
through matchmaking again so this is
basically how I got stuck in this like
loop where I couldn't make join a match
I see maybe it's cuz everyone's
downloading like you would imagine some
people have it already right and so
they're probably playing no every time i
keeps making me think we got yeah right
that's the sound they got me too any new
guns the l star at else are the L star
is a brand new
and it looks super cheap if you've seen
the trailer again he was giving it to us
but like the lie have the Intimidator
let me equip that crazy that's like too
much you know
oh the l star here you go oh yeah let's
check out the skins poetic justice I
need the actual weapon and everything
basic justice this one's like I don't
even know like alien invasion okay make
sense I was gonna say alien vibes I
literally can't get into a game though
yeah is ranked available oh yeah rank is
also a new addition to seasons ooh I
can't here I'm gonna cancel real quick
which is a mistake
there's rank two leagues so we just do
that let's do it bronze fourth bronze
boys try to get out let's try to get out
of bronze here oh I got another welcome
to season 2 screen after I already
looked at it earlier
she's totally fine she's done you might
a hit like that button
oh all right we're gonna try to get into
ranked I don't think yeah it's doing the
same thing someone said reset your game
I already reset it once so unless like a
bunch of people in chat actually are
getting matches like yeah exactly I'm
willing to reset if people are actually
like oh yeah like reset words
so all the tears we got bronze silver
gold platinum diamond apex pretty I see
you're starting to get crafting parts
level 9 u get 120 that's pretty good
trying to get more loot tix which is
good or apex packs because Watson's
passive what skin looks good like that's
always better than the one I spent 1200
arts for sure
oh yeah there's these two now these
skydive emotes oh yeah which is kind of
cool I wonder if that slows you down at
all oh we can't bring too much I tried
so loads oh oh hey we in ranked oh snap
hit record on that so you can't see it
but yeah it's that one
alright we got to move out of bronze oh
you just watching a free character
debated
oh this is a new load screen though I
didn't even notice this alright try
again let's try again shake again we go
track and then once I figure out where
to read these abilities imma let you
guys know about her passive I think it
was like she get is the passive a part
of her she uses the ultimate accelerate
and she gets
instant ultimate or something was I
that's not it it's just that her
ultimate is like pretty good so you want
to just like stock him up or whatever
she's a static defector that's
[Music]
let us annex game oh okay all right this
is on ps4 you guys for those of you
asking yes
all right we're in and we're in range
yeah I wonder if there's anything that
shows like the difference in the map
other than the trailer we got press
square on her all right Scott I can do
it here ya go yeah yeah I know you can
see it here I wasn't sure if you could
do did all right so I'm going my plane
so you guys can watch hey place someone
imma try there's a here's all her stuff
at the bottom wreckage aeneas ultimate
accelerant oh you were right fully
charges Watsons ultimate standing near
interception pylons who's Watson's
tactical pressure which is the shield
which is good great okay fences and then
the ultimate is the thing that sucks up
all the like grenades and all that fun
stuff
alright Wow look us I was I hadn't
played apex in a while to be honest it's
fine like I was on it for a hot minute
and then I just needed a break because
there's no contact all right let's see
there on the map there we good so here
you go oh my goodness where are we going
I have no idea I gonna fly over there
and see if that stuff will kill us if we
land on him yes I want to do a drive-by
yeah my dude I'm gonna drop like various
but I want to like fly by this dude's
face what if we land in his mouth yes
yes yes no I don't know though we we
spent so long getting a GD map oh he's
got stuff in his mouth
yes he's not read maybe he's not a it's
not a meat-eater
oh yeah he's a herbalist that's new this
is new oh my gosh it's exciting new
stuff you Matt oh I just picked up a new
hop-up I think you did nice extended
energy bag Oh gold helmet oh good on
Watson yeah oh I just picked up an
accelerant you want it no no we good
this is so weird like not knowing the
area I'm happy that there's like new
content are where these were these folks
at okay triangle what oh I have another
energy mag and you I don't like a real
symmetric type thing well these fences
are coming down all right you get four
fences at one time okay I still need a
gun oh you do I was too busy admiring
what was going on here I'll take that
I'm so lost right now just because I'm
not used to this
I threw a need in there
well fence you
yeah she jumped off okay all I can offer
is my moral support there's also a hop
up here that I never seen someone grab
that I think oh I can't put my energy
nag on this triple-t oh they down there
I see you're watching all right
oh do you need oh you're good I can do
shield batteries I have to just swap
hairs or are they pushing up the hill
hold on Erin I'm trying
yeah she looks awesome I really like
this there's a knocking down there too
oh I have ultimate already interesting
even if I walk by it stopped the
electric fence oh I see a fence over
there and it's a different color than
ours so they're really so they're way to
see it interesting it usually starts at
11:00 but we start early because
oh I hear shotgun oh man all righty I'm
like trying to mess with these fences in
it I think it's a bad idea
I can recharge my shield I think that's
a really good girl oh he's right there
hit him
oh nice okay
[Music]
this is awesome
the of it it's better than nothing yeah
and I have gold helmet oh we gotta get
his banner yeah we're coming for you
Aaron sorry we're do we're trying to
learn that's a partner right now
me scared all right I'm gonna try to
make my way all right it's going alright
y'all bronzed here let's go hammer point
round for the Mosin oh we this a beacon
like right here huh yeah okay yeah it's
rough out here in the streets
hey I'm responding you Aaron oh right
the shotgun stacks are only 16 now
that's not so far ah not about that life
I need more I'm a spammer Big Mike's a
chill dude we know you have a gold
helmet I can right now I'm weird it's
actually
all right I got
oh the circle no we gotta go oh that's
not an enemy that's just a dragon like
oh yeah we got I saw one check out the
Leviathan we wanted to see if that thing
would step on people to like kill them
you know if you could aggravate it
somehow oh yeah see it starts chumps see
the foot it's about - it's about to do
the bang em if you get your Batum I'll
decide if I die which by the way anybody
watch CEO I watched highlights of
certain matches I'm shocked that a bond
shun I was pretty excited I mean he's
been one of my favorite players but we
hadn't seen much of him in five so I
think it's nice to see like the
comebacks so I'm supposed to like carry
like ultimate accelerants right I think
that's what the dev said like what that
our CL 100 nevermind oh it's cool it's
fine it is I just only have three
I can't how are we oh we kind of bar
yeah we should make moves I should be
putting like fences up huh yeah probably
I mean we don't really have a place
we're holding down right now
once we like oh nice spot inside the
ring maybe don't worry they'll never I
have too much stuff oh I hear action
yeah where there's hello I am let's go
yeah we yes season 2 is live spooky it's
pretty exciting the map is different
we've got Watson yeah
we're gonna try to get that L star at
some point you haven't seen a package or
I haven't been paying attention I guess
either oh you know give away our
position
sounds good oh there's a race tunnel
here which could mean they're over there
all the traps wait why does that trap go
off
he probably shot it okay I was wondering
if the weak are five right now we're
killing yeah let's make the smart please
yeah and yes you can buy Watson if you
have in-game currency right away she is
12,000 just like the other champs or
legends I don't like it I'm just gonna
peek word we're playing two defensive
champions or legends right now so boring
the rest of the map it does look more
green so whatever we were doing oh
there's a package over there to all that
scared me I know buddy looted over here
you there so like her accent yeah I
can't wait to see the Watson cosplayers
I'm going for it I want to know your
self up to later boxes come on I'll
start yeah I'm gonna take that purple
line yeah go for it
unless Aryan gets to it oh you snooze
you lose
so no I'll start off no I'll start this
time it's okay but we're going for it
every time you guys we don't get that
your squads left Oh Spitfire I wouldn't
say this game is pay2win because you can
get that currency in game by sitting on
like are you sure I thought it felt like
98 thousand really yeah it's very
possible o intrinsic Oh it's got five
kills let me play in Watson I know that
for a fact because they were those
banner people the ones that are oh yeah
there's a top squad right now I'm gonna
have to side bust them I know so the
second we heard gunfire package there
has to be an all-star in that I'm going
for it okay we going for L star is not
wins here we got it we got to show that
there's a repulsor going down did that
just crash right now 900
aftermath like I missed it
should at least ping it somewhere knows
keep doing the wrong one yeah so we only
seen a couple of the new
hop up is interesting because you think
there'd be like more there's a ton of
stuff because my fear was that I hear
still hear people oh [ __ ] there's two
there's two oh he's got an L star let's
kill him I guess watch out there's one
above you behind you now I want that L
star bro you better come over here oh
you come down he's up top I got excited
where's this buddy though I don't know
it was a Nazi yeah whoa I was thirsting
for that L start someone just got
respond though D well that wasn't the
guy though yeah okay well that's
oh oh oh yeah I see him I hit him I hit
him twice shields are down he has purple
shield high ground so good game how far
does it reach not this far oh yeah over
here watch out someone's flanking two
people two people
oh yeah oh I got one down you down them
yeah I headshot it let's go should I
push it yeah yeah yeah there's two there
Oh
okay I don't have any knees though oh
they're all here I got down another one
down here's the luckily the guy behind
go with the coffee still up there we
should have all went one way cuz that
guy just got to pick us off at the time
yeah I wonder if he's alone yeah he won
the guy up top one I'm so sad about very
sad too we got 10 RP we're climbing the
ranks surprise machine what is that
noise
they're like after the game noise f
everyone throw the FCI should have
pushed forward because I basically died
to the Pathfinder I named it die to the
people it was but there was two people
down there that was our first game yeah
that's a it's my point of view honestly
like that Watson came out and night I
hit her but I was too low and then that
I looked up and I saw the bastard I wish
her when you said that but then I ended
up killing the cost or knocked the
caustic and then I was lit from the
Watson and then I tried to back off and
then the Pathfinder up top killed me so
the Pathfinder up top had at like a
devotion and the else are nice we need a
patch for sure we need a pad because I
needed a way up there cuz I was willing
to fight that guy but it was like I
can't get up there
exactly alright I don't know if you had
a dip down but
yeah all good those the first king yeah
I don't know how I feel about these
fences y'all know I'd rather have the
gas traps cuz they can kind of throw
them down this like you have to like
place place and like the Pathfinders up
there I'm like cool how my fence is
doing nothing yeah pretty much because
you know it only stops grenades also
alright let's go somewhere else yeah we
gotta we gotta get kills that airbase
for the daily challenge okay it's
summertime summertime fun I'm going over
there oh I guess I'll go here god it's
gonna be so spicy I see all these
shadows oh let's go oh I got a thermal
she must've got body armor that's BS
just can't find a gun I have all the
attachments though okay he's got a P
2020 oh there's a thing up there you
have no you're dead the other way we're
in the other way
just dip out jump on the jump on that
yeah
yeah oh you do why you wanted us to play
that's why oh they'll never get you down
there
we'll never you're never getting out of
there either I'm surprised you're
actually stuck in a crevice cuz you're
not getting out of kinky mantle can you
hold no alright well press F in chat
y'all press F in chat I was like if I go
all the way across they're gonna knock
me down I'm gonna fall anyways okay so
uh but it didn't proc the armor thing it
didn't proc armor on when I hit her so I
thought she was gonna die in one more
shot I would have died anyways cuz
there's two of them I did the good news
is her purple armor might be stuck there
so at least she took the armor with her
they're not getting that purple armor
yes he that was actually the plane I was
going for stay there you might win no
we're not spending an hour and a half or
whatever like I would need the ring to
like Curtis it's okay that was our apps
are coming
all right all right it's fine it's fine
they updated that was so where's I open
like four supply crates and got none I
got attachments and some ammo I got a
hop-up yeah I had thermal and grenade in
the first two I was like sick and a
barrel stabilizer and then I got a
peacekeeper which I felt good about but
then I had two people shooting me and I
was like oh I'm dead I have no armor I
thought I would take one with me but
that didn't happen and then Aaron had a
p20 20 so you know feels bad I had a
purple IRA do it again I might have been
able yeah you could have at least killed
one of them because I think they didn't
have the they didn't have armor oh snap
ariana grande was the highest ranking
champ last match sounds about right
she's pretty godlike all right you know
what let's try this oh yeah okay fine
this area looks mostly the same except
for this like the flaming repulsor tower
thing I still want to try to land and
then surprisingly this side of the map
is pretty the same too
it's mainly on this side all right let's
go for those orders you're awesome
update it is live try new hop-up so yeah
we're trying it we got to try to get
some of the guns we've seen some of the
new hop ops is our only second match the
first match we got third I think we
probably should have won that one we
should I think that a solo on it because
he had high ground
and that last match was a cluster F oh
dude there's a there's a flying monster
right there chillin on a perch Oh
taking the salute box somewhere Oh Moses
couple Mozambique hey you can get those
rounds now
motion I hit him twice but I needed a
hop up no he's pretty far
yeah at the out place oh oh he's a guy
with a frickin mouth thing as we watch
Aaron Loup he's probably buying this
teammate yeah as I hear him rip nowhere
but I like having the challenge is cuz
at least of course those people in the
certain areas I don't know
yeah I'm just gonna try to crawl to
safety
I think y'all are in trouble though cuz
that one guys one guy's got like good
guns and the monster hurt you Mike Mike
be asked I think when the monster stomps
I think it can kill you oh wait I can
jump how do the hop ups look they look
the same but they have different like
icons are they - 18 come on that was
with double Mozambique
not with the knee round stone jump safe
jump further yeah we could do that yeah
challenges up in this yeah I just looked
interesting because I was like I may be
the the daily ones are just randomized
for everyone yeah I would have taken the
are you 45 but I was like panicking
there I think about are we 45 I might
have been able to kill the the Mangler I
was like hot swapping white armor the
whole time
y'all are such a BOTS mmm use watch and
shield yeah I don't even think I had
that there dang but I will I will use it
for sure later I want to suck up but
like the Gibraltar alt or Bangalore old
I feel like with Watson like having your
honor squad our only option right now is
to just make sure we're always huddled
up that's how we're gonna get like max
haven't had anyone walk through my
freaking G defense like how do you get
someone to walk do it it's so visible
like yes unless you like put it in like
a place like that like a reflection of
those like chokes we're like you have no
choice but like if you're like oh I see
a fence I'll go around it's like I don't
know someone's probably gonna be like no
no no you're just playing it wrong and
probably am probably best for like drop
ships maybe we should land on dropship
Oh
Vince off all the doors that's gonna be
tough yeah I told you it's like you got
put one down
put another one down so oh i'm
jumpmaster let's go do you want to go
air base again that's gonna be a super
Spacey oh I can't ping it because the
monsters in the way oh you want to go
far maybe hi drew hi Jeff I think Ryan
says just joking what oh you want to go
to the butt of the monster yeah maybe
something good this Lane with all that
ass that dinosaur but yeah here we go
got a grenade y'all spit fire me the
hell off got that crazy gold skin Oh
energy okay sigh Oh fat a devotion let's
see if I got a fire
well there's an extended energy Maggie
should over there over there
[Music]
oh geez it scared the crap I was looking
at chat seriously was looking at chat
and then I just all of a sudden someone
shooting me oh that's interesting
I don't have a you should pick that up
in case you get longbow true
where was that energy I think it's in
that building okay that guy dropped so
low though because he instead died and
he missed a few loot spots in Spain
Spitfire skin yeah you get this one as
part of the battle pass I think that
scared the crap out of me chat real talk
yeah that's tech guys one shot - backing
on others - is it Watson and something
else you know there's there's - spicy -
spicy spice just let them fight it out
[Music]
cuz it gave me over there there's
another one there that they're fighting
each other
[Music]
what
okay she's down but Watson drop
[Music]
right under us zip that goes I still
need to feed though yeah yeah there's
there's there's someone there she could
be coming to you I don't know
so watch your back nope right here
oh the give me still down there he's not
good now we got oh wait here it might
drones back and it's all class of wild
oh oh I'm only going down right
oh man I got a I just got shredded
because he's up there oh yeah my device
he's all came out one oh you guys should
say there
it was good knowing everyone
I bought the sunsetting oh man the Sun
is setting y'all the Suns getting real
low that's getting real low big guy
sorry it's only a circle one did you
guys kill the other person or did she
eliminated guys are good and then
there's a thing right to your right so
oh my oh don't miss Aaron that was yeah
use her gate yeah I should have put her
gates behind us that was my fault it's
okay it's my first few oh my lord we
must run faster oh good okay Oh Aaron's
gonna Phoenix KITT and then you can just
just do your thing
Oh Aaron's going for another one
y'all aren't on the same page right now
okay oh he's lifting the leg I can't
show it to you guys do you wanna dance
man do you even play apex legends you're
bad now I don't play this game at all
I don't know unless I got lucky on some
of those tools that a guy okay guys
Eric's first time playing would you
would you guys be nicer if I told you is
my first time playing does that change
your perspective not right I was hoping
maybe there'd be some charity that
things knew - oh I got that hop up on
the Mozambique there was some of those
rounds over there watch their team kill
game oh here's a thing I don't know it's
like hard to get a lot of kills no game
unless you drop high-seas choke and
thingy do you have your thing I do let's
just bring the attention whatever bring
it I'm living I'm living that poverty
life right now
so season one boys hey purple knockdown
shield wusers so exciting oh there's a
bird yeah let's go get him does he have
anything good I don't know I can't tell
like they're all sitting up on a perch
now we didn't want to kill you we just
wanted the box I kind of wish it like it
stayed on the ground if you killed it oh
yeah they disappeared how does the
destruction look says he probably wanted
don't mark it
no markets looted oh this is all looted
seeing devotion I have a package like a
blue extended mag on it it's like a
pretty bullet hammer head points on
increases unshielded damage so after I
show you my elite wingman skills which I
don't have
I will then swap to the Mozambique to
finish them off no snap these are the
apex pro league plays you guys didn't
know about exactly oh not on me not not
enough coffee today all I don't know
there's a package you want to try to
play for the package yeah and someone
can respond also yeah oh but they're
right next to the package
oh there's three of them there hopefully
that one person doesn't we've been fun
oh I hear there's one there and one
there you there I'll come back yeah I
see them yeah they're wrapping around
the building
one person is my himself I'm gonna try
to beat him out a little bit they see me
yeah three squads left
Wow I ready yeah you know always right
there
oh there's one in here
[Music]
city purple armor over here they're
coming from this direction
okay I got one again oh my gosh oh man
there's like a lot of people now it's
most pods now use the fence I should
have used the fence I should use the
Force I use your old least got the old
down we should have ran into the
building okay how much damage did you do
double wing man no I had a wing man in
Mozambique nice 6:24 yeah all right two
top threes we're getting close we're
getting close I can feel it
we got this yeah I got to remember to
use defense thanks shot yeah shellfish I
just know like I couldn't stop like
fighting I had to like I think that's
where it's gonna take coordination on
like me and Aaron's part to like give
you some backup
cuz maybe I should use it you can give
me some backup all right and I love
what's her passive do I can sew her so
if you use an ultimate accelerant you
get your ultimate instantly yeah which
is pretty cool and then alright so you
wanna switch to here feet then yeah then
you don't need to record oh and I gotta
get back to this and I got a lot of
headphones
[Music]
intelligence oh oh yeah also I realize
we passed by whatever okay cool it's
like nice how do you destroy fences I
think you can shoot the bottom part of
it yeah that's something we should try
next time and then you can blow up the
ultimate theory we can play I know like
three head shots just now that the
wingman the kills and damage before
leaving the match make fun of my size it
feels 868 damage
bring out your bloodhound mass although
I guess maybe
that's exploit this way we can apply my
husband now and I'm going now
angry just wants to see the monster
what's up arrow welcome back oh no all
right let's break oh there's that guy's
oh there's someone in here
oh there's a monster in there though
things I trapped inside the cage he's
lit those
oh wait you guys have no audio Oh God
aha there we go yeah okay let me bring
your audio back up then bring line down
and then unplug that all right I think
that I forgot him that light plane I
keep trying to throw my boxes down as
the chat
oh man I feel bad okay no one saw that
no no one on chat saw it so I mean you
know I keep thinking I'm lifeline I'll
play lifeline one will probably need it
it's just have it I own every use videos
okay I don't know how to hit middle
thing if you hit middle button you'll
see I had two kills three hundred
something damage oh hey hit continue
yeah one and 126 well yeah I have to get
two kills and hydro dam we can go there
if you want if it's in it in an optimal
position apex still fortnight lol you
mean fortnight stole apex
it stole the ping system it's still the
response system so I find that hilarious
I know I was like let me just put all
the fences here like I think you really
have to stretch them out yeah like you
get more like like mice I play on too
low of a sensitivity to get the real Oh
what do you play agree
Liyana also once it's a bit
disappointing I'm oh yeah I think that
there's definitely use cases for her but
I don't right now I I need to see
someone high level user because I feel
like the traps take a minute to like set
up and yeah I don't know like time one
time the Pathfinder had high ground on
us I was like sick these fences do
nothing but I have gotten killed at
least once maybe twice where I should
have probably put down a fence because
then that she wouldn't have like rushed
me mm-hmm
we had two top threes hydro dam all
right look I'll hide you two legends
agree accents we are playing on ps4 you
know if anyone's following us there's
definitely one person
definitely saw one yeah yeah
gunfire have a good fire it's awesome
bullets coming your way unless I was you
know it's the guys across the way I'm
trying to leave this hydro dam he needs
a weapon you got gas
that's all I can offer and oh yeah we
got a we know 2000 crap he's still out
there there's a P 2020 here for you
pressure just go upstairs oh wait no you
killed a hydro dam right yeah but we we
got go do it then well if you want to
wait for that exam they're fighting over
there
oh we're off are we out let's go
over there guys got trip will take I
have gas everyday yeah me too all right
my vision is clear
oh sure guys I'll put it next to your
shield where'd they go
I hear the one guy killed was close to
you guys he's around me the person's
around these fingers outside you just
wait
[Music]
we laid some fences though you guys just
like okay I couldn't even come help one
time cuz he blocked the door I know I
was trying to get in there because like
the I have my old in there so I can
recharge my shields 12 K 4 Watson's is
pretty cheap to be honest the same thing
credits is pretty easy to get to be
honest like when the other legends were
first released they are all 12 King yep
you can kick down the door I can't kick
down a classic trap though so yes I can
I can't punch or kick down a door but I
cannot punch through a caustics trap
oh yeah that would have been cool Justin
says Watson Pat Watson's passive should
have been no turbocharger needed huh no
it would have been nice
that would have been okey but nice all
right well so much for getting those
hydro dam kills all right here we go
[Music]
well sorry's out junebug again oh man if
disable it dummy it was already armed so
I can't disable it
hi I'm gonna stop responding to check
yeah the thing is for all the stuff I
was saying you guys couldn't see my feet
so I understand why you're saying that
but 100% that it was blocked and trigger
dirty and active double wingman did
anyone drop
[Music]
oh shoot oh shoot we have expired the
champion we expired
[Music]
oh I just walked through someone else's
unless we killed them already
wait what yeah this your right crime
just gonna play hmm I do want to see how
terrible all one shot in the base of the
fence Lestrade we act yes the school
piercer is gold now I noticed that
earlier like the other match yeah you
can't Marley it only takes 12,000 yeah
how do we get the update reset and like
if you're a piss-poor you can pull it
down your options button for season two
or a yep out today
you know when season 1 ended I was like
Nina's gonna be forever in so seasons
yeah yeah that was kind of weird like I
didn't take a second
O'Shea alright anybody see you something
enters the game moving speed slower I
don't know you were saying you felt
slower but I felt like a lifeline was
slower have my oats and have mine
alright attention is coming call it in
now
oh you need some syringes huh or I can
drop you don't you have a wingman no
yeah I have one already yeah I know but
I see they've just placed the fence over
there yep I have a spot for you oh
they're on top this to you there
Oh
okay all right did some things yeah guys
we all know things Elise oh they're
angry they're like we're in the storm
now - oh boy
erin has syringes have you got the
diagram I know do I go back you're a
stranger I don't well I had hella
syringes on my body
nailed it okay it's fine I wasn't gonna
make it but yeah to make defend against
knocks I think if it catches the knocks
it will darn it
yeah I had to go around the mountain too
so like I'm not gonna make it no we're
hella far from circle so like yeah even
having to fight them was bad already so
I put the fence inside and outside and
then I put the trophy system down and
they couldn't they couldn't come in so
that was nice that was one of those
moments yeah
do I have a pack I'm not a new map
there's like nap difference this is
ultimate defend against motor strike yes
believe so it'll eat up the Gibby alt it
I think it'll eat up Bangalore's too
well that monster stomp you it
definitely lifts its leg up so I think
if you're underneath you uh you will die
how you guys like in the season I like
that there's challenges so kind of like
makes you go do certain things I haven't
played enough I still want to try the
Elster yeah we got to try to find is
Chris else favorite apex tree Mary let's
go her fence will tell you if someone
like walked through it and it slows you
for like a second it's kind of like the
gas trap except it's less annoying I
guess a snap you're a G Mike B
[Music]
introducing your champion it's okay by
the time we stop we will have hopefully
made bronze the dealer's choice
nice we're gonna go yeah we start what
challenges are there says awkward it's
mainly like you know do xmi damage with
these certain legends or like get kills
with a certain gun or get kills in a
certain area yeah Ryan knows what
thousand are you gone hi Joe can you
really want this challenges Jonathan
there's a couple new hop ups there's one
that makes it so you do more shield
damage there's also one that does more
damage for unshielded so in theory
trying to make mozambique better i think
it could be it's just weird
just like are you really gonna hold on
to a mozambique that long unless there's
just a lot of someone's here with me I
don't have anything but I'll come throw
some hands
Jesus ran for it it gets too tempting
when I like a teammates fighting and I'm
like I will leave you don't worry I got
a p20 just need your hop-up now Oh
all right the dream combo they're
already reviving somebody are they yeah
someone's landing right here oh no no oh
that guy's got purple armor and oh yeah
there's one down here and there's two
people here and there's bash and running
over here
he wants me get away oh no there you're
all fighting up
I see front-row seats
that's like dice so many people crawling
around dad oh no there's one there's oh
they're up over here two of them
crashing just took off but there's a
lots incoming free oh nice Watson's on
top he's on top of the house ow did you
die
yeah he just shot me he's on top of the
house I have no heavy ammo now but I
thirsted his two buddies I see I'm sorry
every time I see his path finder all I
think about is fashion it's really hard
not to wait you have the hop up no you
are the hop up it's okay snatch and run
snatch me out screw it for the chat
Watson is not free you gotta use the old
the in-game currency noise save in the
squad okay at least I could climb up
here and there's respawn vegan right
here
pretty good Rafa asked how big was the
update you know when I sign into the
game this morning it was like make sure
you clear at least 20 gigs but when I
downloaded it was only like 7 so could
be different for everybody else but yeah
early kind of our circle Austin says I'm
not the only one that calls in Bastion
think
thank you I'm seeing
especially when he's like all happy
at least fashions relative
feel like sorry that was my box that he
took from me try that those fenced looks
useless it depends I mean you can kind
of block people off I guess that leaves
it depends on like area I think like
wherever you're having your battle open
areas probably not so much
[Music]
[Music]
we got a minute let's not get stuck
outside the ring again yeah
not feeling that here gunfire yeah it's
like it sounded far though all those
circles moving any more now I don't know
man what am I am thinking good question
my brain my brains exposed
oh wait
nice slowly please via hominin here I'll
hear less once we get to the circle
whenever the heck that is whenever that
is
hey-oh is just he was stomping yeah I
thought so much we feel that earthquake
I do I think you could die to that here
I'm pretty sure did you do too late Oh
someone's throwing arcs
okay I got one you put down your thing
oh yeah I thought I had my old oh wait
there's another one yeah but wasn't
there a pathfinder did you kill them can
you get crushed by the dinosaurs we done
though it seems possible and I feel like
you didn't revive me
oh my bad my butt no it's all good I
don't have
[Music]
everything okay I'm gonna start running
so we got a minute
yeah wasn't that gold box is called
piercer
yeah all right I'm ready to run six
squads left he was in I think you just
trying to find more leave you okay so
are you horny by with the little bang is
not bad oh yeah I just got the disrupter
rounds oh why didn't you take skull
piercer for long though I did we did I'm
going through bunker you're going
through bunker oh yeah right I closed
supply I'm gonna wrap around cuz I'm too
far to go back that way and pie can I
die I'm gonna rock out at this I 45
don't think FUNKER was looted actually
the thing I don't really get about it I
could get but it's supposed to do more
damage to shield like you know what your
clothes are you really gonna
okay oh all these good guns in here and
I should get it but whatever pop-ups new
hop up Co all right we're off
we're in the ring they're over there far
okay
oh yeah I see him
try to be stealthy here they're making
their way across and then they're trying
to get to that package mm-hmm I see I'm
gonna go check to the hosts are yeah if
it's there I'll give it to you
oh I don't know are they inside yep lol
I'm not going that way that boxes are in
there I'm just watching traps okay you
can shoot the base of the chap once
enter
they eat it up never all their watch are
you smoking
I mean Oh
is it three of them are away you guys I
think there's an another person
yeah they're rapping I was waiting to
respond using all our ammo on my shields
Russia Russia
oh she's one choppers ding I should have
put the fence behind me first and then
put the other one in front
oh it's fine it's fine right now
I do like Watson's over I actually I
kind of like the idea of having her um
you know fences for in round three oh we
ranked uh-oh all right all right I got
one of my two kills in the hydro dam
though finish top three is bloodhound
well that's not happening on the stream
today deal two hundred damage and water
treatment okay
the disrupter rounds apparently takes
shield off faster so if you see someone
that has like shield in theory if you're
landing your shots you'll probably melt
through the shield faster no I'm not
Persian I
that is just my handle 45 disruptor
mm-hmm it seemed pretty good I really
only use it like one good time in a
fight and I kind of like totally cleaved
Bastion I'm not gonna play lifeline but
you can play watching I'm just I'm
actually if I should for Campos you have
to pay for the chin but you can get the
currency you need by just playing the
game you don't actually have to pay any
real dollars for it so don't get psyched
out got 3rd partied what happened I
should just stayed with there I thought
I was gonna push with you yeah I thought
he was too but he must have saw someone
and it stops because a lifeline I lost
the one on one with the lifeline but she
was violate one or two shows I am
Chinese dad to pay for Watson it's like
like where's here yeah it's not a new
map there's just two leviathans now and
then it's parts of the map where became
inside they were over each area is
different that's new right there and
then there's like new buildings there's
like a new tower thing right there that
trying to oh wait I don't I'm showing
them and then I'm like wait there on
your feet there repulsors down can
people see Watson shaft yeah it's very
visible
but like he said it's like one shot to
the base yeah it's kind of like the
cosmic traps where the life coach tips I
haven't heard you drop those nuggets of
wisdom today all right there's a purple
flyer stay positive and we will win you
win your one-on-ones we will guarantee
victory my luck with these supplies dude
have nothing to keep that flyer the
flyer has a purple on it I should take
the Scout instead but I still want to
mess around this are you for a funny
girl I just need to find the hop-up for
what the are you 45 Oh
chillin on perches oh no my dream yes he
dropped it uh-oh
purple shield sometimes when I play
games like back to back
I forget that like I didn't pick
something up because I think already had
it this kidding
oh I should probably get caught up in it
shows Watson cosmetics if you scrub back
to the beginning of the wrongness of it
alright alright I am bad at looting this
is actual facts I just land and hope for
the best
I like please let there be soft out as
plenty of land where everyone yay
but it's Washington cost it's like
they're tokens or the credits or
whatever so if you have 12,000 saved up
you can buy right away yeah now you may
see that
I'd even check the ring oh we gotta go
we gotta go there is definitely someone
like near Scholl towners oh you are far
huh yeah I was kind of inching my way
towards the ring I guess you are guess I
will loot these things in your baggage I
need an extended like mag are you coming
to us are we coming to you um I will
come to you guys
ah you know as far as shooters go I come
from like halo and halo 2 and you know
before these days is about a Royale and
looting back in my day everybody had
same gun and the same below it I was
pretty much so I I kind of felt bad
after but rude I wonder if they get
pinged if somebody else uses their jump
at something oh it's the ring
[Music]
oh my gosh it was like nothing happening
and then all of a sudden hey everyone I
was like I hear people plus two points
the dream I did 52 damage in one shot
because I only fired like one shot that
hooky get a purple Packard Oh a
level-five you get a purple pack that's
pretty good night les I yeah bye Jordan
Luke they are on the map there's two of
them how the hell do you lose your first
gunfight you know height advantage and
they saw his first they also sandwich
ice you know those are a few reasons how
you can lose in the first gunfight
perhaps I don't know anchors how dare
you is that actual facts is that
actually I've been waiting I've been
waiting to see that gosh that was
trending and then I wouldn't looked at
it and it was just people like hype for
the possibility like I don't see it yet
and I don't want to see it so there's
like this 1% chance in my heart maybe we
can do a sign-and-trade to get kauai and
then all will be fine in the world oh my
goodness but there's no way it's
absolutely he's gone to one of the hele
teams I think there's been no there's
been no updates on Kauai so how dare you
don't do that to me
codex says he hasn't signed it
that's like - free - I have the high
ground Anakin hi alright don't want a
cure be skills
hi drew let's try eating us - spices get
your base goes since it's all the
waiters
five people at drama won't get any kills
if they don't come that's true that is
true we're fine - it's Gucci oh wait I
was like a million with the legs yeah
look at that sigh gap and observe by gap
go through the underbelly
alright get some loot get some slit
no whammies oh can she connect to other
Watson straps or what yeah cuz one's
mine or maybe it automatically connects
it bad guys
[Music]
backside circuits broken
so
can I get some armor please I know I
didn't have any armor I was like this is
this is already bad know what we should
do is probably get out of rings ring
does fun though we can go back to
regular now we can stand ranked I don't
care we're all in at this point that's
like we're also like a pretty low in
rank to everyone's starting everything
now they here get that select-fire hopup
yeah I loved I love to get a select I
don't know right now if only I could get
everything out was my fault for sending
us to the hospital
I just want to flying in this little
bite then yeah yeah hey I flew through
the thigh gap so I'm pretty I brought
that oh I had two prowlers to rock to
top threes and then in the two top
threes we got singe - real bad yeah we
did some we didn't do our normal shot
which is to let the first two too much
by it with me and against me because
that happens sometimes
but so far Watson seems cool I did
finally have somebody like run through
my fins and it ping me where they were
and I look okay so I do like that
but I just feel like we haven't been in
too many optimal situations or we can
actually like make good use of the
fences like the one time we really did
have a really good position on the map
we ended up dying to the story I'm like
Tralee after sounds like what you guys
want to go flying over the Leviathan
again go over there okay we're under it
we're not in a good position to thigh
gap it up either so fly by I don't even
think you're happy I can make this yeah
we try to fly by it yeah we'll get a
good view let's check out over there
big beasts Friendly Giant
just eaten some trees I think we're
doing so they're close enough never
doubt Oh
oh jeez oh no they had to go run to this
side though yeah I'm just gonna grab
this and then I'm out of here
oh shoot this or is someone in here
oh no there's something else anyone
passes through here no I open the door
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I'll take the longbow ok got see good
shoot him
oh this they're building that's crazy
the Watson traps don't go away once you
guys yeah interesting
could be a psych-out you guys sending me
friend requests notifications are on
that's what you get I know you guys
don't that was asking mr. Pathfinder
is this titanfall the game is made by
the same thing your update was funny by
the gauge another one what do you like
more of the r99 or the carbine
do you have your havoc still yes then
take that
oh yeah I forgot new hopper turn off
notifications in a sec man angry oh oh
hey okay
assume pushing I guess so turn off
notifications after this because it's
blocking my mini-map
guys you're upsetting the Leviathan your
ruckus was that person by themselves
[Music]
but I got to use my ultimate disrupter
rounds or bullets 200 I was trying to
stay alive but those syringes don't do
enough alright I need to turn these off
are doing too much yeah you know that's
where I struggle in this game right it's
like do you run and leave behind your
team cuz then it's like makes it less
fun to like play by yourself I mean I
don't know I don't know how you're gonna
I mean you could try yeah but their hope
is that we can kill them because it was
a 2v2 for you guys oh I just got leave
no it's a 2v2 for you guys at that point
so in theory hopefully you guys won the
to v2 and then revived because then I
can heal we can out heal the first
circle with lifeline no problem how you
feel about dealer replacing Katie not
great but it's better than getting
nothing
oh man I'm like totally gonna be honest
the whole Katie situation made me not
like it changed my perspective my
perspective on the kawaii situation yeah
because it's like Hawaii did sit out
that whole year but now he's like to a
point where he can play and it not be
scary and then Katie came back early and
then look what happened now you want a
championship
time who is that play guys play didn't
get hurt I don't care people call me bad
this game call me bad at games but then
they try to play me and then they get
bodied so I don't really care it's all
good and that's how battle royale goes
sometimes sometimes you land you don't
get it good sometimes the ring will kill
you it's all good I'm drinking some
coffee because all right I have an
addiction all right where are we going
leads away wherever you want Air Base
Air Base is probably that's asbestos
fashion
you're probably dead
there's someone in front of us well
we're going for it well I'm going for it
oh dude oh gosh oh gosh oh gosh okay
shoot that way that's crazy
quick errand loot the other box there's
one person here thanks guys for doing
all the work cuz I don't know to pick up
weapons I also Grenada tend to panic a
lot she's popping off oh we're in the
ring did you know I me okay
okay they're gonna believe keep telling
yourself that I think he grabbed and
tried to grab those Aaron it's not worth
it's super words okay
Danny I didn't get a kill need to kill
that airbase oh yeah we shoulda gave
that one to you no that's all good
we're we do oh I see someone over town
it's on the other side around the top
oh he just put a Pathfinder thing
I can't from the outside though as a
distraction
oh they're up top
[Music]
as mirages nice the fence is doing its
job wait hold on
[Music]
my second kill feel good all right dang
it's 12:30 already yeah do you wanna run
yeah one more all right this is the one
this was the one yeah you know I'm a
tough day yeah I mean battle Royales
there are a whole different beast man
whole different beast you can't hide the
chat race myth there is an option to do
that yeah this dream runs in 1080
where's my xbox one doesn't stream
sniping you sick come get me good I mean
if you can find us on that delay that's
pretty impressive actually yes plus you
kill me when my back was turned to you
so long I mean good job I guess that's
usually how battle Royales are I just
got booted okay I shall in fighting
maybe they're young you invite oh I just
got Erin in here so I'll invite you okay
boom I can't ready up every team stream
tomorrow now they're playing a Mario
community and there's also not gonna be
a stream on Thursday and Friday
Independence Day I can't ready up what
is going on here I mean leaving
they'll be out yes oh now I can't join
okay well we got anybody doing yeah
joining us now I can ready up to who so
worth all right let's go there we go
success except he's not reading up now
in a match Wow okay what is happening I
think he probably got queued up without
knowing it well interesting that's where
it you can still join someone's party if
you're in a queue hmm maybe he'll leave
a new - can you right-click no that's
alright
interesting I don't have an option to
boot I could leave but then we might not
get Watson again yeah I think I can join
you now wait I did it again I'm joining
you there we go so he's out of match
yeah he's in the party right now there
we go
alright this is the last one this is the
run the urn this is the winner it's
gotta be by skin I already bought a skin
mm-hmm
oh I didn't buy a skin I actually don't
have enough first a good skin anyway
yeah so we got a ace of Sparks probably
the best one so far fly-by-wire cyber
secure somebody had that yeah yeah yeah
I remember
I don't I do like her makeup but I don't
like everything else it bolt as soon as
you come out nah just the yellow star
the L star which we still haven't even
tried to do it's true we can just try to
go chase the packages but they actually
haven't been dropping as much as I
thought they would or they're not in the
right spots I think we lost Aaron oh
well your first opinion well this is
Solis is that you will run all righty
what a great last run huh or maybe we
drop pop and hot inside yeah maybe we
survive it and win it mean every now we
just gotta get one of those good drops
you know
I would have bought a skin I just don't
have that much money
let's go buy it with or craft materials
yeah what I really call it currency that
was the one thing I was annoyed by is
that we weren't still earning like FX
back 100 I think that's kind of annoying
all right we want to go let's uh did you
get your two at hydro I got one drop
skully and love skully so we're gonna
try to get her daily challenge done I
just need one more
thanks JD appreciate it there is no wall
unless I yeah monster looking like a
t-rex from Jurassic Park well bit
the broken-down repulsor
really
we oh shoot I'm so bad at landing
anywhere the momentum carry you oh I
guess you're not doing a daily okay I
guess that's all right Oh better bring
it over there though okay I have a
couple of mags and some hammer I'm going
to drop this see oops the amount of
times I pick up things I don't want in
this game is master nautical interesting
that the extended mag doesn't actually
show in this thing know what that's
weird
so hey I did the extended mag onto this
thing and it didn't actually like oh
yeah cuz there's no space for anything
yeah I didn't show that it actually did
anything yeah I noticed that too
all right we are far from the circle
let's go through this thing all right
longbow Voltas and energy SMG I haven't
seen it I don't think that's in yet if
it is I haven't haven't seen it I
thought they're only adding the whole
star you know if you see a helmet all
right it's like if I checked my brain
[Music]
you have you know yeah there's more down
this corridor swing men
some supply thing over here I'm about to
get stomped on raise your leg Leviathan
okay Oh two packages we do when you want
to go to kind of far though yeah I go
through these
oh they show like the outline of the
Leviathan on the mini-map
no I don't know what's up for fragrance
there we passed the helmet pay attention
thanks I don't think the volts in here
asking
[Music]
so far we haven't seen anybody go
through this corridor I want to I get
like an audio cue if someone shoots my
fence down
all right we're supposed to go to the
package well that's too late now
oh there's one here too okay all right
how do we want to do this
I don't know good question they must
know I was looking at them because he
get that little pink there's one oh yeah
I see them
there's three there's three the whole
squad they're going back to the right
should we it looks like they're running
that directionally yeah I don't know do
whatever you want
we in this area yeah
sneak up on them I just think open land
is probably not watching this best
police
and the Reno commander coming to you top
six squads weird I'm not even seen
people get killed in the kill feed great
it's been very quiet which I kind of
hate vibes mad because you're getting
burned up by the storm fire to the right
that sounds like a different gun
can't go up
we can't go I just want to fight someone
in the beginning and not have to chase
are you should just drop husband also we
need I don't know what happened she just
left all right now we got three let's
see what happens
bad things and we got a drop hot is it
or else we're just gonna be running
around the whole map it's true it's
unfortunate it happens I mean it's all
good it's all good I think when I first
started playing like battle Royales in
general I was like god this is so
annoying and I hate it but then once you
like forget that you can't play a battle
royale like a normal shooter yeah then
it's all you got disconnected again what
is going on or he's not actually there
all right it doesn't matter this is last
game
Aaron it's all good yeah the other thing
about Watson too is like if we drop to
safe she's like actually useless it's a
we get into a fight and even then I
don't know like you just you have to
like get them to want to like walk into
your stuff it's like hard to like you're
not offensively gonna put fences down
all right all right
wish us luck we're going air base yeah
knowing you I see hella people oh it's
our Tillery my fault
oh no one landed in this bill
yeah hi I have an EVA ok oh there's a
lot of fighting over there I'm crawling
and crawling just go here because
everyone oh yeah it's all good I didn't
have much hope all right well yeah there
it is
I mean you know we tried our best it
happened so like find good uses with
Watson I definitely think that her kit
is cool but it's not cool if you dropped
to safe and it's like hard to draw up
hot and user but I think people gotta
figure it out yeah there's a couple
times where you did lay it in front of
like a door mm-hm and then they didn't
cross the door right yeah yeah that
actually hold for those situations but
you gotta see I'm gonna keep using her
though see if I can like figure out
better things or her but um totally hope
you guys enjoyed the stream so far we
try to get as many hops we didn't get
our hands on I'll star issues disruptors
good though
45 in notes on my first
I agree I only got to use the Mozambique
Appa for like a second it was like early
so I can't really tell how that is but
yeah but yeah so go ahead and get uh
Watson today
she's like 12,000 of these little
in-game coins and season two is live
there's ring to mode and all that good
stuff
so check it out hope you guys enjoyed
and please some apex we'll see you guys
next time